is Matt Miller on the phone line right
now from Bleacher Report I believe so
okay Matt Miller who we've never had on
this show so I enjoy following him on
Twitter and I enjoy his work for
bleacher report man who knows quite a
bit about this here draft here on the
Rich Eisen show how are you man hey
thanks for having me out rich can talk
to you wherever I found you where are
you calling in fat I'm in the middle of
Manhattan right now you guys get to hang
out in Dallas and eat barbecue and I get
to come to bleacher report in New York
it's been the week up here all right so
what are you hearing from up there about
the first overall selection in this
draft yeah with you I started hearing
the same thing last night you know
people I think everyone in the NFL we
all kind of talked to the same my group
of people and they start texting you say
you know hey there's a lot of talk about
Baker Mayfield and I agree I think it
would be it would be shocking right I
mean we all know it's gonna be a
quarterback but I do think it would be a
surprise if it were Baker I know people
in his camp that thought his interview
with them went really really well and
when he left there he was there for like
two and a half days and when he left
they were like hey we love you man but
we can't dress you and in you know
whether you want to compare him to
Johnny Manziel or not I think there are
just too many comparisons where he's a
great quarterback he's a heck of a
prospect but you I don't know that you
can draft another you know six foot tall
spread run around quarterback coming out
of the state of Texas when you so
historically flamed on Johnny Manziel
yeah but I mean they aren't the same in
terms of you know ability although hold
on a second by that I the the the quote
that Mayfield was had attributed to him
about why he did not study the Los
Angeles chargers playbook was one of the
first things that I've heard over the
last you know two three months that
would give me pause in any way shape or
form in regards to drafting him but then
again I work and not to say he's Deion
Sanders is a quarterback I work with
Deion Sanders who would talk to teams
that that he didn't think had a chance
in drafting him and he said I'm not even
interviewing with you where do you stand
each subject no I I think Baker is an
interesting guy and and I think the
man-thong comparisons are lazy but I'm
with you like that that story's not
great and then I don't know if you want
behind bakery series and I'm not trying
to plug it for them but it was really
interesting to me that his mom dad and
brother were super nervously he was
going to stay in LA and train after the
Rose Bowl you know that it it wasn't
maybe the best atmosphere for him to be
out there unsupervised and you know here
we are we for the draft and it seems
like he's made it without getting in any
trouble but I think it is a little bit
of a concern and you know I've spent a
lot of time around banker weather you
know the Senior Bowl or the combine and
he's he's great every teammate loves him
he's a great leader he's a little fiery
at times but I think that's part of the
chip that you want you know and it works
for Tom Brady and it works for Aaron
Rodgers so it kind of it would be
hypocritical to say I can't work for
Baker if he can find a way to control it
a little bit at NFL Draft Scout is how
you can follow Matt Miller the a senior
lead NFL draft writer for bleacher
report calling in here on the Rich Eisen
show so doing this evaluation Cleveland
has to do it how do you evaluate the
quarterbacks at the top of this draft
then yeah I think I'm kind of in line
with everybody else you know you could
poke holes and every one of these
quarterbacks and list reasons they
shouldn't be the top guy but I think in
the end of the day spamed Arnold gives
you the best like best bet to be a
franchise quarterback and in five years
he might not be the best one because
guys like Josh Allen and Lamar Jackson
have so much upside but I think in five
years he's not gonna be the worst you
know if he doesn't if he doesn't hate
his feeling he's still pretty good
quarterback and for Cleveland I think
that psychology has to come into play oh
we've been bad for 20 years and we keep
missing on this maybe it's time to just
take the safe bet who also happens to be
really really good and you know it's
asked to do a lot of things at USC that
are Pro ready he's got to carry a team
that wasn't very good and he only got
better late in game so there's there's a
lot to like with Arnold and he's a young
kid in 2021 you're almost 21 years old
so there's also room for him to learn
and grow and and become a better player
than we saw him and not even two years
of starting at USC so you have in your
mock draft you've got because we've said
you've got an interesting choice for the
Giants here because I've said that
they've got pretty much five choices the
Giants
that they take a quarterback they take
Berkeley they trade out
they take they surprise everybody and
take Quentin Nelson although you've got
a figure figuring out a way for the
Giants to put him next to Nate's older
for a while would be just a spectacular
way to keep Eli Manning upright for a
few more years and then you have choice
5 Bradley Chubb why do you think that
that's what the Giants are eventually
going to decide to do in a couple of
days yeah I'll give you a spoiler alert
that's actually changing my life that
comes out Thursday so ok got closer to
time and I backed off that job would be
a fit though in that three-four defense
they're going to run you put him a weak
side backer and for several reason he's
ended incredible you know it's a guy
who's just dominated NC State but all
the talk goes to the quarterbacks or
steak or Berkeley and that's why I have
the Giants taken to like you were saying
you have Eli Manning and it seems like
they believe that he can do the job for
two to three more years they signs
Nate's older every move that they've
made to me at least points to the idea
of loading up around Eli and seeing what
they have in Davis Webb good blast front
off threat to the third round last year
so you go and say call Barclay and we've
seen it so many times you know last year
didn't Blake bortles Leonard fournette
give Cam Newton Christian McCaffrey you
know you have Jared Goff and Todd Gurley
working all together and even you know
the Cowboys wanted to give Tony Romo
Ezekiel Elliott before he got hurt so I
think that is one really smart way to
try to extend this window with Eli
Manning and hopefully make another run
because that defense is actually pretty
good and they have some targets at
receiver and tight in and they can just
kind of all get on the same page they
could be a sneaky dangerous team next
year so who's a sneaky good pick for
first round who's who do you think would
be a great value pick for a Thursday
night which is a nice phrase meaning
somebody who's either a sleeper or comes
up and is chosen in a spot that's a
lower than you think his talent level
should have him yeah you know the guy
rich did I keep going back to just
hating her status out Carolina tied in
to play minor league baseball got the
yips
couldn't cut it as a pitcher ends up
playing tight in for South Carolina and
very very good player he's a little bit
older but a team like the Baltimore
Ravens where they can just plug him
tonight
and it's more of a finished product so
you don't care about the fact that he's
25 years old because he's going to get
on the field right away and hopefully
give you something in the middle of the
field I mean their sign and every
receiver they can to try to fill a need
there which makes me think that they
could really go tight in to try to give
Joe Flacco that huh that guy he has a
head since what Todd Heap without
they're running around
what about defensively on the defensive
side of it defensively yeah I think that
you don't look at someone like Arden T
is probably the biggest wild card and
the question weren't coming out LSU
you know played at 280 pounds this year
he also played at 235 pounds this year
so he's a really hard guy to gauge where
he's going to go it might not be
Thursday night it might be Friday
because of some all film questions but
if you go back to 2016 when he was at a
good playing were complete and when he
was locked in he was one of the best
defensive ends in the country so he's a
really intriguing name to watch it a
guy's our team's gonna bet on his talent
at the end of the first round will they
be scared off and hear his name called
on Friday last one for you Matt Miller
or bleacher report how many quarterbacks
go in the first round in a couple nights
when it all comes down to it man I wish
I knew the answer I think you over
unders a five and a half I would say six
I do think I think Lamar Jackson block
to go round one and it will see Mason
Rudolph I could absolutely see a team
like New England or the Doyle and Saints
we're wanting to get that quarterback in
the future and also wanting to get him
for five years especially after watching
Jimmy Garoppolo leave a little bit
earlier than they probably would have
liked now you can get a guy that you can
lock in for a full five years and I
don't think Tom Brady will probably done
playing by then no but I think you make
a good point Matt and that's something
that we've rarely heard brought up when
we when we hear Lamar Jackson's gonna
fall out of the first round that
somebody would definitely knock on
Philadelphia's door 32nd overall to
whatever
draft capital is required to get up
there to make sure that you get him for
a fifth year as opposed to falling into
the second round and to Jimmy Garoppolo
territory I think that that's a that's a
smart shrewd analysis of why Lamar
Jackson is definitely not going to drop
to round number two yeah and Billy
doesn't have it picking around two or
three so they're gonna be moe
it's a trade back I think and recoup
some of that capital they've trade it
off to build this incredible roster they
have so there that's that's probably the
most likely trade to watch for as well
appreciate the time we'll chat again
soon
yeah good man good luck this we dare you
to that's Matt Miller check him out on
bleacher report at NFL Draft Scout on
Twitter he's the co-host of something
called the stick to football podcast the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience